Hi, today we will make this effect. The
inspiration comes from uh the movie
Doctor Strange. I think it's from the
2016 Doctor Strange. Before we begin our
tutorial, I will explain the principle
generally. We can see the house. this
line, this line, this line. They clipped
the geometry with just a normal method.
You can't make this. I made this by the
shade mode.
Uh in shading there there is like which
one? The first one. Yeah, I use RFA. RFA
is the most important one in this
effect. The first step of this effect is
the geometry node. And uh just a little
bit of geometry node I will show you.
It's very simple. First we need a mesh
circle
and the instance on
on it. And here I will I will just use a
cube for demonstration. Just click it
just link it to instance and uh link it
here.
Okay.
And use a transform geometry node here.
Yeah. To make it a 90° because because I
prefer this way
and
I think there are too much too too many
cubes. I need a less. So we need to
decrease the vertices.
So four. Yeah, four is okay. And next we
make the animation.
We also use transform geometry and uh we
took the rotation like this. So
we use a combine XYZ click to rotation
and
with
with time here put the time here seconds
connected to X and you will have this
effect.
So this is the basic effect.
And here another one we need to put the
integers here. Put the vertices here.
And then
we store we need to store the integer
store the integer here.
and we call it uh
number.
So, so I I think that's all we need.
And uh before we start the shading, we
need to increase this because I want it
obvious, very obvious for you to see
that.
So then we need to save it.
Okay, this is the first part and next
let's go to the CD mode here.
So
I will make a bigger cube here. So just
uh
just for like for easier explanation.
So first I will show you the basic
principle I make this. So we control T.
We have this basic node assist and
delete the image
and use separate XYZ
and remember to link the object to
vector and then control shift and left
click of mouse. So you will have this.
So here I use Z.
So this uh and uh you can see
that uh it's blurry in the middle. So I
don't want that. So I use mass
here
greater than if it's greater than zero
we want it to be
uh one. The white the value of white is
one. So that's what we need. And after
we make this basic structure and you
rotate you rotate this X Y Z UI find Y
direction you can make it move.
The principle of this effect is that
clip the geometry like this here is
alpha. The angle is alpha.
So this alpha comes from like
2 pi divided the number.
So we will get uh an angle 2 pi is 360°
and the number is what we stored in our
last step. It's a number of the
instance.
So here if if the number like um
increased this alpha decrease.
So here
like here is the original line.
If we make it zero here is original line
and uh this is alpha we need the first
first we need to like divide it by two.
we divide then this alpha into
two half alpha. So what we need to do is
to make this alpha here. So my method is
to
like first make the first uh half alpha
here and then stretch this line here. uh
you will f you will find this one is
vertical
and uh this half alpha half alpha and
this angle is beta alpha and beta uh
equals 90°
so you will find also here half alpha
half alpha and beta it's also 90° so
it's 90° here
so we want the white space to
be Here
first we need to make this half alpha
here. So
we need to make uh this angle.
So here uh I I think it's uh the angle
here is
90°. So 90 degree is a
uh half pi divide
half r. So this is this angle. Uh but
actually like if you rotate it in this
direction there will be minus here. So
minus this you will get this angle. So
this is the principle
and let's make it by this principle.
So I will
just a random value if if if the
I divide two. Yes. Yes. If it's a four
instance. So the angle we get is this
value. And the first step we
uh divide divide two.
Yeah, you can see.
And this this equals
half r uh
subtract half pi. So first divide and f
next subtract
subtract half pi. pi half pi here and
then connect it to y. So we have this
angle
because it's 90° so it's like this. So
this is the first part
and uh we need to make another part is
here
here with uh com first this part another
this part and then combine them
together.
So by making this is uh this much much
more simple.
So we just need to
multiply
-1
and copy all of them here
connected to y
and uh then you preview it. It's uh
reversed. It's reversed. Yeah. So just
by multiply negative one.
And the next step we need to combine
them together. So here I just use
multiply
because the white part is one, black
part is zero. Uh 0 multiply one is zero.
So white part uh by using multiply we
get only the white part.
So yeah that's what we have.
And uh next we link the shed here we
connect to RFI. So we have this.
So you can see
it already have effect on the geometry
inside. So we hide this value and go to
the original geometry nodes
and uh we need to reply uh replace this
value.
here I use
no attribute
and uh what we stored I think it's
called a number the number of the
geometry so to get the ar we need a math
node
as what I said 2 pi divide number
two pi divide number here
and
connect it to here.
So I think that's that's what I what
what I need. So let's go to geometry
nodes here.
Let's try if if it worked.
So here
and uh yeah the integer is here. That's
the number of the instance. If we
increase the number you can see the
clipping. I think it's right. Yeah. And
I think we're almost there. Just uh
remember to reduce
this value to very small value. So you
will have this. And let's play the
animation.
Okay. Uh let's clean all all this. Let's
clean all this.
Okay.
Okay. And I think we get what we want.
So next we need to find a geometry to
replace this cube. So if you
find a house in
I think it's called blank kit
and uh if you have like this house here
if you want to make this animation by
this house
uh it's here. So first step you need to
you must do ltp clear parent. If we
don't do this, you can't make the
animation.
Yeah.
So, delete this uh empty
and uh then let's go to shading.
Go to material.
So, we will copy all of the ARA part.
What happened?
Okay. There there is something wrong
with the with the shading. Yeah, that is
right.
So first,
so first we go to cube uh copy the ara
part and then go to the geometry here.
Go to the building here. Paste them here
and uh connect it to ARA
and go to another uh this is the roof
and uh paste it here. connect to alpha
and then you see everything disappeared.
Uh don't worry we will fix it later. So
we go to geometry node and uh we drag
the I yeah
drag the horse here
and uh
connect replace it with the cube here.
hide the original host
and let's see if it worked. Yeah, it
worked. You can see the empty part.
It worked.
So, let's increase the numbers. You can
see it's perfect. Okay, that's a whole
tutorial. Hope you like it. Thank you
for watching. Bye-bye.